in the last video we talked a little bit
about compounding interest and our
example was
com interest that compounds or annually
not continuously like we would see in a
lot of banks but i really just wanted to
let you understand that although the
idea is simple every year you get 10
percent of the money that you started
off with that year and it's called
compounding because the next year you
get money not just on your initial
deposit but you also get money or
interest on the interest from previous
years that's why it's called compounding
interest and although that idea is
pretty simple we saw that the math can
get a little tricky i mean if you have a
a reasonable calculator you can solve
for some of these things if you know how
to do it but it's very
it's nearly impossible to actually do it
in your head for example at the last at
the end of the last video we said hey if
i have a hundred dollars and if i'm
compounding it ten percent a year that's
where this one comes from how long does
it take for me to double my money and
end up with this equation and to solve
that equation
most calculators don't have a log base
1.1 and i've shown this in other videos
this you could also say x is equal to
log
base 10 of 2 divided by log base 1.1 of
2. this is another way to calculate log
base 1.1 of 2. i say this oh sorry
this should be log base 10 of 1.1 and i
say this because most calculators have a
log base 10 function and this and this
are equivalent and i've proven it in
other videos so in order to say how long
does it take to double my money at 10 a
year you'd have to put that in your
calculator and let's try it out
let's try it out right here so we're
going to have
te2 and we're going to take the
logarithm of that it's 0.3
divided by
divided by i'll do open parenthesis here
just to be careful divided by 1.1 and
the logarithm of that
and we close the parentheses
is equal to
7.27 years so roughly 7.3 years
so this is roughly equal to 7.3 years
and as we saw in the last video this is
not necessarily trivial to set up but
even if you understand the math here
it's not easy to do this in your head
it's literally almost impossible to do
in your head so i want to show you is a
is a is a rule to approximate this
question how long does it take for you
to double your money and that rule
this is called the rule of 72
sometimes it's the rule of 70 or the
rule of 69 but rule of 72 tends to be
the most typical one especially when
you're talking about
of compounding over set periods of time
maybe not continuous compounding
continuous compounding you'll get closer
to 69 or 70 but i'll show you what i
mean in a second so to answer that same
question so let's say i have 10 percent
10 percent
compounding annually
compounding
annually
10 interest compounding annually using
the rule of 72 i say how long does it
take for me to double my money i
literally take 72
i take 72 that's why it's called the
rule of 72. i divide it by the
percentage so the percentage is 10 it's
decimal representation is 0.1 but it's
10 per 100 percentage so 72 divided by
10 and i get
7.2 it was annual so 7.2 years if this
was 10 compounding monthly it would be
7.2 months so i got 7.2 years which is
pretty darn close to what we got by
doing all that fancy math
similarly let's say that i'm compounding
let's do another problem
let's say i'm i have i'm compounding 6
let's say six percent compounding
annually
compounding
it's like that well using the rule of 72
i just take 72
divided by the 6 and i get 6 goes into
72 12 times so it'll take 12 years for
me to double my money if i'm getting 6
percent on my money compounding annually
let's see if that works out so we
learned last time the other way to solve
this would literally be we would say x
the answer to this should be close to
log
base anything really of 2 divided by
well this is where we get the doubling
our money from the 2 means 2 times our
money divided by base log base of
whatever this is 10 of in this case
instead of 1.1 it's going to be 1.06
so you can already see it's a little bit
more difficult get our calculator out
so we have
2 log of that
divided by
1.06
log of that
is
equal to
11.89 so about 11.9 so when you do all
the fancy math we got 11.9
so once again you see this is a pretty
good approximation and this math
this math is much much much simpler than
this math and i think most of us can do
this in our head so this is actually a
good way to impress people and just to
get a better sense of how good this
number 72 is what i did is i plotted
on a spreadsheet i said okay here's the
different interest rates this is the
actual time it would take to double so
i'm i'm actually using
this formula right here to figure out
the actual the precise amount of time
it'll take to double let's say for this
is in years if we're compounding
annually so if you're at one percent
it'll take you 70 years to double your
money at 25 percent it'll only take you
a little over three years to double your
money so this is the actual this is the
correct
this is the correct
and i will
and i'll do this in blue this is the
correct
number right here so this is actual
right there
that right there is the
actual
and i plotted it here too if you look at
the blue line that's the actual so i
didn't plot all of them if you started i
think i started at maybe four percent
so if you look at four percent it takes
you 17.6 years to double your money so
four percent it takes 17.6 years to
double your money so that's that dot
right there on the blue at five percent
it takes you at five percent it takes
you
14 years to double your money and so
this should also give you an
appreciation that every percentage
really does matter when you're talking
about compounding interest when it takes
two percent it takes you 35 years to
double your money one percent takes you
70 years so it takes you you double your
money twice as fast so it really is
really important especially if you think
about doubling your money or even
tripling your money for that matter
now in red
in red over here
i said what does the rule of 72 predict
this is what the rule so if you just
take 72 and divide it by one percent you
get 72. if you take 72 divided by 4 you
get 18. rule of 74
rule of 72 says it'll take you 18 years
to double your money at a 4 interest
rate when the actual answer is
17.7 years so it's pretty close so
that's what's in red
right there
that's what's in red right there and you
can see so i've plotted it here the
curves are pretty close for
low interest rates for low interest
rates so that's these interest rates
over here
the rule of 72 the rule of 72
slightly
overestimates how long it'll take to
double your money and as you get to
higher interest rates it slightly
underestimates how long it'll take you
to double your money and just if you had
to think about you know is g is 72
really the best number
well this is kind of what i did if i
just if you just take the interest rate
and you multiply it by the actual
doubling time and here you get a bunch
of numbers for low interest rate 69
works good for very high interest rates
78 works good but if you look at this 72
looks like a pretty good approximation
you can see it took us pretty well all
the way from when what i graphed here
four percent all the way to 25 percent
which is most of the interest rates most
of us are going to deal with for most of
our lives so hopefully you found that
useful it's a very easy way to figure
out how fast it's going to take you to
double your mind let's do one more just
for fun
i have a
i have a oh i don't know a four well i
already did that
let's say i have a
a nine percent
nine percent annual compounding how long
does it take for me to my double my
money
well 72
divided by nine is equal to eight years
it'll take me eight years to double my
money and the actual answer if this is
usually this is the approximate answer
using the rule of 72 the actual answer
nine percent is 8.04 years so once again
in our head we were able to do a very
very very good approximation